[Music]
[Music]
it's only natural that with a teaser
trailer as short and cryptic as the one
we got for breath to watch sequel
we as a fan base are going to make a lot
of assumptions
the game will be set on the ground
princess zelda might be playable
ganondorf will be the main villain the
zonai will play a role in the story and
link's hand will transform into all
kinds of different items
there's nothing wrong with this of
course i mean we barely have anything to
work with and no gameplay to go off so
speculation is only logical it's either
that or
not making any breathable 2 content at
all although it's impossible to know
anything for sure at this stage some of
these assumptions like the aspect of
link's magic hand
do at least hold some weight not because
of the trailer itself but due to some of
the knowledge we have surrounding breath
the wild's development cycle and its dlc
since the game's launch in 2017 nintendo
has released a lot of details about the
creative process surrounding the game's
development
concept art scrapped ideas development
notes and behind the scenes either in
video format
live presentations interviews and of
course masterwork slash creating a
champion
because of this we are able to get a
sneak peek into some of the ideas
nintendo was toying with before the game
saw the light of day
some of these ideas ended up not making
it into the game at all others did but
in a different way than they were
initially intended this allows us to
make some rough predictions as to what
breathalot sequel
might have in store for us since even
when a concept doesn't make it into the
final game nintendo usually doesn't just
throw them by the wayside and oftentimes
we would see some of these ideas pop up
in a later installment
a good example being mario galaxy 2
which mainly consisted of unused ideas
that didn't make it into galaxy 1.
as such as soon as we saw link's hand
getting afflicted in the reveal trailer
it goes without saying that many made
the connection to this concept art where
we see nintendo toying around
with the idea of link's arm transforming
into all kinds of different tools and
weapons
an idea which could have been scrapped
in favor of the sheikah slate until we
learn more about the game this is just a
prediction of course
and the correlation between the imagery
of link's hand and the concept art could
just be a coincidence and nothing more
that being said another assumption
people have made either as a prediction
or
just wishful thinking is the return of
bigger more complex dungeons akin to the
ones we encountered in previous
installments whether or not you
personally count the divine beasts the
shrines and hyrule castle as
actual dungeons yes or no is up to you
miyamoto doesn't seem to regard them as
such but then again
if they felt like dungeons to you then
who are we to say that you are wrong
this video is also not about which is
better the older the new we all have our
preferences but one thing's for sure
breath of the wild's take was definitely
very different from what we were used to
and in this video together with conrad
from the commonwealth realm we want to
take a look at some aspects which may
foreshadow a return to form when it
comes to zelda dungeons these include
hints and clues from breathtawa's
development cycle the sequel's trailer
game design reasons fan feedback and
more so without further ado
here are 5 hints and reasons for the
return of dungeons in breath of the wild
too
breath of the wild saw quite a lot of
changes and revisions during its
development but by far the biggest ones
took place between 2014 when the game
was first announced and the first proper
trailer at e3 in 2016.
it's obvious that between these two
periods in time a lot of crucial
decisions were made about which
direction the game should take
and this is most evident from the 2014
game awards presentation
the first gameplay demonstration
following the announcement of the game
six months prior here we see miyamoto
and aonuma showing off the early
gameplay concepts of breath the wild
which at this point in time
didn't have a name yet the paraglider
which was still a sail cloth at this
point like the one from skyward sword
horse riding fighting enemies and other
little details about the controls in the
game's engine
at some point during the presentation
miyamoto states the following
this looks a bit suspicious we must be
near a dungeon
what's interesting is that aonuma is
clearly exploring an early build of the
farron region at this moment
during his remark miyamoto points at two
owl statues standing side by side
a common occurrence in farren and here's
the thing farren only ended up playing a
very minute role in the game
it has no relevance to the main plot of
the game at all and more importantly
it doesn't feature a divine beast
there's a good chance that at this stage
of development the divine beasts were
either not yet conceptualized or at the
very least one of many ideas the staff
was considering and no decision was yet
made about which direction to take
this is further supported by the
complete absence of the sheikah slate
during this presentation
the slate wasn't introduced until e3 of
2016
more than one and a half years later not
only that but during the presentation
the two are confident that the game will
release somewhere in 2015
and well we all know how that panned out
the sheikah slade and divine beasts are
closely connected story wise as are the
shrines and chica towers none of which
are visible during this presentation
we do see an early concept of using
towers to scout the area but these don't
look anything like the shika towers and
are instead just wooden structures with
a platform on top
so could it be that at this stage of
development the team was still set on
making regular dungeons
ones which were not based on shika
technology and one of them was supposed
to be located in farren somewhere
perhaps
a forest-based dungeon if this is true
then miyamoto's remark about a dungeon
being located in farren could be another
one of those early ideas one which also
ended up being scrapped in favor of the
sheik attack just like the idea of
link's afflicted hand
and might still be on the shelf to be
used for the sequel
the owl statues were present from the
very beginning of breath of the wild
announcement as early as the very first
reveal
so perhaps nintendo had bigger plans for
these statues being tied to a big story
event and subsequently a more classic
dungeon to go with it
and surprise surprise what is one of the
first things we see in the reveal
trailer of breath the wild 2
zonai based architecture of which our
statues are a big part of which brings
us to the next point
the fact that we see a large dark cave
system in the reveal trailer
may seem trivial but is actually a huge
contrast to breath the wild
hyrule was vast and full of secrets
short but large
complex caves were not part of that
mystery in fact
even the biggest caves found in the game
are child's play compared to previous
installments
they rarely if ever branch off into
multiple directions and generally don't
consist of more than one room or
corridor
they also aren't dark by any means and
can be easily explored without the use
of a light source
naturally there is the possibility that
the cable we see in the reveal trailer
is only tied to cutscenes and nothing
more or even completely absent
from the final game but if it's not then
nintendo could be setting us
up for something bigger a recurring
theme of exploring
vast underground locations these don't
necessarily have to be tied to one
single theme
like a cave but also other types of
indoor environments
in fact there is another piece of
concept art which might have
some connection to the whole idea of
venturing underground and solving
mysteries in a dark
dungeon-like setting namely this one
shown at the gdc session
in 2017 by art director satoru takizawa
here we see link investigating an
ancient scripture in what seems to be an
unlit
man-made temple or underground structure
notice how he's also carrying a lantern
something he didn't have
in the final game which might be
included in the sequel speaking of the
sequel
doesn't the setting in this artwork of
lighting up a wall to investigate
ancient writings look a bit
familiar perhaps another scrapped idea
that will make its way into the sequel
in some shape or form
exploring dark ancient crypts to uncover
mysteries from times unknown
there was definitely a lack of enclosed
spaces to explore and brought
the wild yes we had the shrines divine
beasts and castles but the variety and
aesthetics and atmosphere of indoor
environments definitely left a lot to be
desired
the fact that nintendo presents us with
this grand underground cave could again
be a hint of things to come
especially with braftawal's overworld
having been completely comped
out and explored to its full extent
hence more focus on exploring enclosed
spaces
would make sense if they plan to revisit
the same world
something aonuma has already confirmed
will be the case
adding a new province somewhere probably
won't be enough to make the game feel
less than a glorified dlc pack
hence why a plethora of new explorable
dungeonesque locations hidden within the
same overworld map
will be a great way to expand an already
huge
game it would also present a lot more
options for story and gameplay which
leads us into
next aspects
as much as we enjoy the divine beasts
and shrines on our first playthrough
there are a few things that make a
return of the mechanical giants and
puzzle-based mini-challenges
problematic one of which being that the
divine beast
and shrine concept is severely limited
for most people
they were an absolute joy to tackle yet
at the same time they quickly lose steam
over the course of the adventure
especially the divine beasts this is
because they are all based
on the same core idea i would argue that
by the time the champion's ballot came
along
the idea had already overstayed its
welcome and the review scores for this
dlc pack
reflects that sentiment more shrines and
another defined beast like challenge
simply wasn't enough to peak people's
interest we'd already seen the
mechanical giants four times and in the
case of the shrines
120 times the idea had run its course
this problem is a lot less prevalent
than previous titles since the dungeon
variety provided
so much more to work with as late as
2011 in skyward sword
nintendo was still bringing in brand new
ideas never before
seen in the zelda series new locations
new puzzles new ways to traverse a
dungeon and so on
this kind of variation is simply a lot
harder to accomplish with the divine
beasts since they all work the same way
mechanically
and the size although large for a moving
behemoth is still limited to a specific
dimension
inside breath of the wild's overworld
unless they grow to the size of a titan
like the ones from xenoblade chronicles
2 there will always be a massive
restriction on how
big these things can actually get second
is the story implications
breath the while 2 needs to stand out
from its predecessor in order to avoid
feeling like a simple expansion
rather than a proper sequel and i simply
see very little options for the divine
beasts making a return as the game's
central dungeons
again their size is limited and we
already explored them on the inside
extensively there's simply no reason to
go through the same motion
again they may still be around in the
overworld but their inclusion in the
story would have to serve a different
purpose this time around
last but not least the beasts were tied
to the story arc of the champions
which have passed on to the afterlife at
the end of breath the wild
it is possible that the four giants play
another role revolving around the
so-called new
champions if not for the fact that age
of calamity already explored this idea
and will probably feel very repetitive
if this is revisited again
yes some of this is subjective with a
fanbase as big and passionate as the
zelda community there needs to be a
middle ground to keep everyone
interested speaking of the fans
[Music]
despite all the praise breath of the
wild has received since its release
even a great game isn't without its
criticism most changes to the zelda
formula brought forth by the game were a
welcome inclusion but when looking at
the main consensus
similar complaints keep coming back
fragile weapons
rain the lack of story and of course
most importantly
not being allowed to pet dogs what were
you thinking nintendo
among these general complaints the
absence of dungeons is one of those
recurring sentiments the divine beasts
may have been necessary to break the
zelda conventions a breath of fresh air
after decades of doing the same old
routine
yet it's undeniable that the zelda
fanbase was heavily divided on whether
or not the divine beasts were a
satisfying replacement for the dungeons
of
old and here's where we need to keep one
thing in mind nintendo does
listen it may not always seem that way
as nintendo rarely communicates about
these kinds of matters to us directly
but every now and again we are given
hints that aonuma and his team are not
completely oblivious to fan feedback and
demands
as an example director hidomaru
fujibayashi stated in an interview that
quote i think while we were working on
both the main game and the dlc it was a
process of constantly getting lots of
different new ideas as we refined the
game
and finding out new things we wanted to
do even in situations like this
talking to people and finding out that
people want to pet dogs gives me a lot
of motivation
a lot of ideas for things we could put
into the game in turn aunuma also
brought up something similar in an
interview with famitsu
saying that although it's not easy to
answer all the expectations of all
players he does recognize that the
significance and continuation of the
series is found in its fanbase
yes the zelda team listens and since the
lack of proper dungeons still remains a
general complaint it is definitely not
too far out there to assume that for the
sequel they might have taken this
sentiment to heart
breath of the wild was in many ways an
experiment a way to breathe new life
into the series but this doesn't mean
that
every change we saw will be a mainstay
for instance after the release of
skyward sword aunuma made the argument
that moving forward the series would
probably keep motion controls as a
central mechanic
and while motion controls aren't
completely gone in breath of the wild
they definitely took a back seat and are
almost completely optional
and i'm willing to bet that fan feedback
after skyward sword's release
did play a role in this speaking of
skyward sword
[Music]
if breath wall 2 is set for release in
2021
or at the latest in early 2022 then the
release of skyward sword hd
may hold some significance for the
direction of the sequel
out of all zelda games skyward sword is
by far the game that shares the closest
connection to breath the wild the
goddess hylia statues
fire's voice inside the master sword the
free springs which are almost an exact
redesign
of those found in skyward sword the
three elemental dragons
din roll nedra farish and so on
having played for skyward sword will
make it obvious just how much of its
lore was adapted by breath of the wild
and that makes it all the more fitting
that skyward sword hd will be the game
preceding breath the wild 2's launch
this game will essentially serve as the
appetizer to the long-awaited sequel and
here's what really matters
skyward sword arguably has some of the
most original dungeon designs in the
entire series
from the mysterious ancient system to
the pirate ship and its unique time
shift stone mechanic
to skykeep with its ability to shift the
layout of the dungeon itself around
like it or hate it skyward sword had
little to no shortages in the dungeon
department
this might be a good incentive for the
zelda team to include strong and unique
dungeons to breath the wild sequel after
all it might be a bit of a
disappointment for people
if they have just come off of playing a
zelda game with great dungeons only to
have the new game be completely devoid
of dungeons altogether aka
skyward sword might have actually forced
the zelda team
to change up the dungeon formula for the
sequel to avoid
new fans of the series being somewhat
underwhelmed after picking up skyward
sword for the first time
the same thing could be said about story
but that is a topic for another time
and there you have it 5 reasons why
dungeons could make a return in breath
the wild sequel
be sure to share your thoughts in the
comments below are you more in favor of
a return to form or would you rather see
the divine beast concept being expanded
upon
also if you want to see more regarding
the possibilities of breath to wall 2's
dungeons be sure to check out my very
first video
where me and nintendo black crisis
explore some of the ideas and concepts
with that said
thank you to conrad for joining me be
sure to watch his video over on
commonwealth realm where together we
will go more in depth on dungeons in
breathtak 2 so
go check it out thank you all so much
for watching and a big thanks to my
gracious patreon supporters and members
who make these videos possible
also please give a warm welcome to my
latest supporters
magikarp kingdom it's elektra and
squall045
a fine addition to my collection no but
seriously thank you all so much
and that is all for now i hope to see
you next time this is dawn signing off
and have a good one
[Music]
mmm
[Music]
you